good evening we're going to get started
I'm here to welcome you on behalf of
Denmark Wiggly and then proske director
events at the School of Architecture
justified way of brief introduction we
are very pleased to have good colleagues
and friends of ours back from Japan
takoyaki kubo with morrie Memorial
Foundation and professor Ishikawa from
Meiji University and this is the second
year that they're going to be presenting
this really interesting index that it
particularly are planning students and
our real estate students but all of our
students relationship to take note of so
without further ado I will pass it over
to talk the way the evening is going to
go is that they're going to be a few
presentations than some responses and
then we will open it up to questions
thank you
you
okay good evening I'm tag google from
the more you memory the foundation it's
our pleasure to come back here again to
this place and so we'd like to start so
today so we have three people to be
present so first here's professor each
cover from he's a Dean of professional
graduate school governance studies at
major university and also a director of
the more even memory of validation that
are logged and also this is a Peter
Moore cotorreo he's an associate
professor department of geography at
Hunter College New York and myself at
i'm a senior research at institute order
for armor strategy that's amore member
of foundation so let's get me started so
just give you a brief introduction of
the memory memory foundation so we are
established in 1981 so and we were
founded by the founder of the morning
building in the in Tokyo which is a
major developer in Tokyo and so mori
building does a lot of urban development
especially in Tokyo in minato words and
so have been done plenty of our project
so maybe I go over later and also some
projects in Shanghai including this
world financial center and also recently
some more projects are happening like a
soul and other agent cities so the
foundation was our foundation was
founded because such more building is a
private sector so there's a limitation
to create some certain urban policy so
that's why are the maury they've
established the foundation the public
list sector so and it can take on the
more memorable nation conducts basically
the research proposal to make Tokyo more
livable so and this is one project
undergoing the future our grand design
for Tokyo towards 2030
and also another research this is the
proposal to how to make the elderly are
friendly city for Tokyo like this and so
and the Institute for Urban strategy
that I belong is has been established in
2008 chair by hazel takenaka who is a
former minister for economic and fiscal
policy under koizumi cabinet so and
Institute research more global issues
with I take to Tokyo under the go voyage
of cities and also and there was a
desire to major authentic position Tokyo
among the global cities then the insta
forever strategy issue the first Japan
Baisakhi ranking survey for global
varsity index 2008 and in the same time
are based on the problems and findings
from the district index so we also
Imperial creating a future urban goals
and strategies for Tokyo towards the
2050 then are coming back to the global
varsity index so it features so it
explores the comprehensive power of
cities that attracted creative people
and Nixon companies wandering the world
and also it featured indicates such
comprehensive power by creating rankings
for the world's major cities and it
applies multiple visions compared to the
conventional rankings as the first Jeff
and based city ranking and so the
ultimate goal is not to create the
rankings of the cities but it's rather
it aims that identify the future of
cities and encourage people to
reconsider the attractiveness of cities
and also intends to be a useful tool to
establish urban strategy clarifying the
strengths and weaknesses of cities so
this is our organization for our current
research so this is Professor heizo
Takenaka and also we got the advisor Sir
Peter Hall in London and also saskia
sassen is also one of the committee
members as
as well another as well as Richard
bender from UC Berkeley and professor
ichikawa is also a committee members but
also he is also a principal for our
working then let me switch out the
professor each cohesin explains the
recent findings for the GPCR 2010 take a
taco ah today I direct explained Justin
URI they developed rust months the index
2010 how we can find this year the
ranking I just briefly explain about 30
minutes what I've done here first of all
we chose 35 were the top cities so the
high of the explain why we chose these
65 cities there are 14 cities in Europe
and Africa certain cities in Asia it
suited in America so there are several
criteria first criteria is top ten
cities in major city rankings in the
world now such as the global financial
center index down positive London World
War the Centers vaca mass index by
MasterCard and City the opportunity by
PricewaterhouseCoopers second criteria
is major cities in the top 10 countries
listed in the rankings produced by a
World Economic Forum and iMod in
Switzerland so the criteria is a kind of
our original point because of this is
the first Japanese ranking based in Asia
so reading cities in eight years asian
cities and the bricks are just selected
for this 35 cities the final you can
find in these cities all over the world
algorithms friend Flo creating function
based rankings which all the six
functions to America's ranking economy
researcher development culture
interaction of ability ecology unnatural
environment accessibility each function
has several indicator group in case of
economy there are 44 indicators the
Indian cultures indicator group of
indicators a market of top tables
economic vitality business environment
regulations and risks so just the same
way in case of research and development
there are three and in case of cultural
interaction terrify give ability they
are for ecology and natural environment
there are free accessibility there are
two so in the critter group such as the
market octo attractiveness this is
composed by three indicators okay I can
say the case of an economy there are
indicator groups of four groups here but
each a group has similar indicator this
means such as a case of market doctor
ultra trees this market of toughness is
composed of our indicators three
indicators gdp gdp per capita GDP growth
rate so in case you cannot buy 30 there
are three indicators business
environment there are five indicators
regulations on the disks there are three
indicators so finery
there are 14 indicators composing this
function by column so in case of
research and development there are three
groups research background readiness for
accept accepting and supporting
researchers and our Randy achievement so
each group has several indicators this
means each group is composed of several
indicators so it may be better skipping
this go to the time constraint anyway so
in case of culture interaction there are
five groups channel setting potential
accommodation environment resources for
attracting geezers shopping and dining
the volume of an international
interaction and you can find each other
several indicators livability indicators
group working environment cost of living
security and safety life support
functions so we have to say at some
point about here working environment and
the first indicator is total working
hours well it might be just the fan you
are not in case of working hours if you
work hard harder it's a negative honking
its first point and cost of living a
resident of residences and average price
ripple special for average rental
residences if that is expensive more
expensive it should be ranked hour or so
this is the kind of important fact for
rum a crowd kings in the major cities
like London or New York but we can find
more about that later then ecology on
the natural environment while including
a natural environment
and the policies if we have a good
policy to controlling other pollutions
you have a better choice to get the
better rankings accessibility there are
two universal interest of transportation
and inner city transported there are two
categories okay finally we have a 69
indicators and within sixty night
indicator 15 I indicators come from
statistics and South indicators come
from Cristiano survey we did in 35
cities we actually a directory answers
from residences there so this is a final
flow of this ranking system finally we
can get comprehensive ranked by
functions and I have to say one more
system in this ranking we have a five
groups of the city managers researchers
artists visitors and residents from the
appeal points we have also the rankings
so now we have a 69 indicators in case
of managers which over the 40 90 meters
good for her you make of are you of
managers preference same to others in
case the researchers 34 actors are
artists 24 the visitors 24 and
residences certina so how we could find
these indicators okay in case managers
we have eight factors accumulation of
enterprises and business deals to
politics economy and disaster risk there
are eight factors so we chose 49
indicators from 69 indicators related to
deeds eight factors for the evaluation
of managers reference researcher there
are six categories qualities of research
institutions researchers and directors
to bidding environment finally salty for
indicators were chosen artist five
factors cultural stimulus to living
environment finally 24 indicators were
saluted visitors there are seven factors
from autumn silver cities to mobility
several factors and 24 indicator the
children finally all residents there are
several indicators economic environment
live environment work environment
educational environment later
opportunities safety and security and
medical environment these are for the
factors to evaluate the residents
opinions referencing finally saw tina
indicators are chosen ok so the result
this is a result of a comprehensive
ranking this year
so you can find top four cities and
others this means we have a top four
cities they have a very big
competitiveness now and secondary group
about 10 to 15 cities following to
top four cities so this is just the same
condition same characters we compared
with that of last year but some
difference happens this year most city
or opacity decreased their scores so you
can find here 209 score by just to let
the to mark and when we see that for top
cities Paris decreased most and Tokyo
decreased least in secondary group city
most of them decreased the schools but
some difference in several cities what
that
in top four cities Tokyo has decreased
least know much when compared to other
cities ok this is the changes from last
year to GC in grill marks shows that
getting up blood shows catacutan so
generally you can find eight east asian
cities most of them are just getting up
north america and europe several
varieties so the most important point
here is we have to think about the
economic conditions like last few years
we had a big a kind of resistant it's
just a cut but conditioner belconnen
caused by severe i'm wrong so this
single actually affected is 40 70
this is a case of economy just a more
Korean eastern city has a getting up
north american cities most of all them
forgetting goethe accepted you look in
Europe well german city is a good but
other the quiet or worse so this is a
typical will contain happened for for
this year this is a table over schools
the new york well this is a top in the
world now bus to the city has a weak
point in a give ability on the
environment but two functions but other
functions new has a very good point the
finally new card are locked at the frost
london that's very close to new york and
the weak points are same to New York
give ability and the environment are not
necessarily good here so it is in this
pattern just saved to New York and
London Paris a different city this is a
kind of the city feature the overall
power and the weak point is only one
here not too much environment others are
almost moderate quite good Tokyo it is
similar to Paris but you can find Tokyo
has no to top function so the reason
Tokyo has only the fourth position
then next comment about North American
cities as you can find the new catalytic
power so what happened for other cities
in economy other cities is generally
speaking just modern adjusta less than
half i'ma justa other average here
sister it means under average accepted
new R&D is much better most city has the
schools are more than the average Carter
interaction is quite different right
it's a bearish dependable cities give
ability well this quite interesting well
Canadians have the better scores rather
than Americans so we can find some weak
points here for this function for
Lincoln cities environment well because
over the policies for environmental
protection for American cities generally
American cities has a robust force in
this field yep ability also this ability
Neal Cotts good point other different
the early part was for the Los Angeles
proton tells how society Scott artista
push
universities just this color pink well
economies are two types of the city's
stolen got weaker but this is a group
here R&D why don't own a particle Papa
other different the sunset culture
intellectual quite similar capability
and environment this is the great good
points for European cities when we see
the case of North American cities indian
cities this green color shows asian
cities so there are a kind of two groups
tokyo singapore so hong kong and on the
other hand osaka beijing shanghai of
Coca taipei charanpur Baumbach there are
kind of two extremes here but within
these four well not all but for the four
functions tokyo at the top in Asia but
to two functions are different singapore
well similar to Tokyo but resultant so
it'll serve Hong Kong that's a good
point but turf no good for livability
and environment maybe they complain
about them some reason he ok asian
cities for the Osaka but this is another
group I just called the secondary group
in Asian cities just kind of average
Beijing very strongly in economy and
culture interactions but other the quiet
was chaha similar to Beijing but that I
native ability fukuoka taipei quran po
bangkok we'll just a kind over the
nossek entire group religion ctz so
finally we can find the steerer Tokyo
has a good position in Asia but maybe
changing quite soon after space ranking
well tops for city has a good positions
in these categories manager researcher
artist visitor as an accept Paris in
management results
and Tokyo just kind of a same group are
in these four cities
so come easy on top cities what happens
here so we have to see the case of the
managers well as you can find now Tokyo
has a very big Hawaiian economy its
second following a new york but for the
prevalence of management it's quite
different top with singapore seconded
Hong Kong Tokyo has only hips and
Shanghai and the Beijing is just coming
close to total now so this is a kind of
very weak points for total now
researcher Boston and soul has good
positions artists bearing Vienna has
good positions visitors Beijing Shanghai
have a good positions residence Zurich
and bearing have good depletion so other
parts we can find some a kind of variety
/ interesting points in these actors run
okay we see more about photo cities the
definition analysis now livability and
environment New York is under 50 economy
for regulations and risks except the
London other three cities as a resident
50 is an average are only
new casa top following by tokyo culture
interaction well this is a quite weak
point for Tokyo Tokyo has occurred two
more scores are compared to other three
cities and for volume introduction our
London has a big score durability well
as i said already the cost of living is
a negative point for these large cities
but but still this we need the
discussion you know because of a bigger
team and the coastal breathing is
getting the higher so it should be in a
kind of a point for every late so after
me now top will explain another ranking
in a city language in the sinister
lurking at this part is different just a
validation so whenever we may be this
kind of ranking you know we have to make
a kind of different ideas and a kind of
interpretations how to use these data by
the way it is ranking for 35 cities this
cost over ribbon should be counted as a
negative part and the for life support
functions Paris and Tokyo is a very
stern of points and these parts will be
shown more strongly by the inner city
ranking later tactics printer
environment Japanese it has very strong
environmental policy rather than other
cities accessibility well every time we
have to see the weak point of Tokyo
because of international airline flights
and also doctors from city center to
airport Tokyo has a still weak point
here and inner city transportation
London that is
varies within the four cities a common
this is a four HR cities where I Tokyo
have a big for us but for recognitions
and risks singapore and hong kong has a
special policies so these are very good
points for the two cities R&D but is a
very strong point for Tokyo's and now
cell is just getting close to Tokyo now
and challenge cities still this is a
problem to be solved for them Roger
interaction well Beijing Shanghai DISA
kind of a country the policy they have
very big policy to increase in this part
including the construction of a hotels
Tokyo has a good for shopping dining and
the volume introduction good for
Singapore so there are some variety here
for this function in Asia livability
well this is again the weak points for
18 cities and what this world is funny
well this it is now they are working
hard that's near the point comment well
whenever the country is getting the
power stronger that they work hard but
still in this ranking this is a negative
point and that is a good point for
European cities and in different cities
arrive support functions again chinese
cities have with points when we back to
the coast of real challenges easy okay
good cheaper and the security and safety
channel Cities program I've support
functions beijing and singapore the
problem except Shanghai Shanghai it's
quite good so even in Chinese cities
Shanghai and Beijing had some different
pattern it environment well good for
Tokyo's and pollution duties Hong Kong
Beijing Shanghai at the different now
but natural environment what is a kind
of natural point so Tokyo cannot change
natural settings accessibility well
international connection singapore and
hong kong are the priority more than
other cities accessibility now they're
getting better especially case of
shanghai now the network hope subway
lines is already exceeding the tokyo
network on subway lines now then come to
the more detail for top four cities New
York what's the point what's good point
so a weak points well read show the
strong points for the kind of research
and development and the economy but for
the post of reading ecology and the
environment and the relational risks
this is under the average this black
line shows the average of four top
cities random similar to to the New York
but infrastructure in inner city
transportation is a weak point again
Horace well possibly but good but other
quite a moderate Tokyo after four big
weak points and Tokyo the character
shows the Tokyo health and not necessary
but register on the point singapore well
just kind of work in this case there are
still quite small point for the red
demark hong kong so Beijing
cha
then come back to distribution of
indicators for top four cities New York
these are new york or new product
opposition's while point here is this is
average so you can see here if you have
a more squad here finally you can get
higher positions over rankings this is
the case of a new yo you can find more
in the 70 to 90 here Lando similar
tuning up but this is a more average
here and quite small numbers here this
here Paris is a moderate so the contrast
to Tokyo is different Tokyo has a not
stronger point here from 70 to 90 that
the reason tocate cannot exceed the
ranking over New York so far so this is
a pattern of top for city is a New York
and London Paris and Tokyo so if i am
the policymakers we can find the easy
how to get the score of tokyo this path
should be come down here which we should
take more here so the weak points are
quite similar to other cities even for
New York we're very weak point here but
this part is more stronger than other
three cities I thought the reason still
knew your kicks are top rack in the
world now so we'll see more about Tokyo
what's good for Tokyo number of all
posts never registered industrial
property rights R&D expenditure safety
river oaks shopping satisfactory level
of dining and GDP and some others punk
charity of a public transportation is
good and number book world top 300
companies and the number
with iso 14001 this are typically point
and we have so many discussions every
day we have a discussion about these
corporate tax rate this is the auto
discussions travel time between inner
city and interchange airport so quite
recently our government had a discussion
to decrease this rate but every year we
have discussions never happened for this
part already you are changing and now we
have a quite rapid to access from
airport to city centre now so maybe next
year this part will be not weak want a
look more in Tokyo you'll be changing
and this is just a kind of crutch you to
expression for this year's GPC I so
later one taco will explain more about
inner city ranking pouring thank you
very much
okay thank you professor Cho so I like
to continue so as a professor said this
year we initiated the new research for
global power in Earth's the index very
similar to the GPC I but a bit different
so on so to do that so why we do that is
because we thought the city we are
measuring base by the city's power and
but those power could be generated in
the very heart of the city is what we
expected like the Manhattan is maybe
represent the most of the power of New
York so and first are we selected the
cities because we are going to look up
the very deep deeper aspects to the city
so we cannot do all those 35 6 cities so
we selected our top cities like New York
and London Paris and then a gem our top
cities and Tokyo Singapore Hong Kong and
soul and Shanghai so this chart
represents the GPC is a result but so
this access the score and this axis
represents the population of each cities
so you can see these top cities they are
not always are saying our population see
the Paris is very small but still has a
very high score vs are these Chinese
huge cities is a bunch of populations
they are still in the lower score and
also this the other one this one this
axis is for the area for their cities so
and even like Shanghai evasion they
cannot fit in this this chart so anyway
so the tiny Paris has a quite big power
so then we focused on the size of Paris
could be her
some are key to the inner city so this
is a scale comparison for each city so
this is Paris in New York so and this
also the rent and Shanghai then we focus
on the size of Paris which is about ah
so this is Paris and this is a map of
Paris so this a bounder is a Paris and
this is actually a five-kilometer radius
which is about three miles so and so
first we try to define this
five-kilometer radius as a inner city
but also a supplementary we are also a
defining another five kilometers so five
kilometer and tinker meter radius for us
as inner city for each city and we
plotted each landmarks and most of the
landmarks are concentrating of course in
within the inner city like this is New
York is my have done and said London so
this is a Trafalgar Square and within
the 10 kilometer you can still see the
Docklands around here so we are mostly
keeping the major aspects or you know
functions within these inner city that
we define and Tokyo as well so we set
the Center for at Imperial Palace and
Singapore actually the center is around
the marina bay but we set it at oh ja
rule for this time and Hong Kong are for
the center the colon team shot see is a
center study and install actually the
city center this is a practical center
now but now it's shifting towards the
south which is the next to the u.s. face
and this is Shanghai we set the center
of the People's Square
and then we selected also the indicator
so we cannot apply all the 69 indicators
because we want to visualize all the
indicators in the map so we selected 20s
from these indicators so and we selected
so the people it which is a kind a
density in the city and those are tall
buildings and top our company so we
named that these as vital property and
then for the culture property we
selected top universities and theatres
concert halls museums and Garland's and
stadiums and four interactive property
visited convention centers and embassies
and consulates and international schools
and for the luxury property so we set up
five star hotels and top restaurants and
those are brand name shops and for the
hospitals and shopping centers green and
water coverage receptivity is as a
amenity property and finally the mobile
T property it's conditional subway and
rail transit and also the highway and
also international transport
international transport it does not
always exist inside inner city but we
thought it's very important for the
living in the inner city to get the very
easy access towards the overseas so that
we included this so and let me just go
over so this is the first when the
population after this color shows the
density of each city within the inner
city so the densest is it's actually
it's about 20 more than five fifty
thousand people per square kilometer and
so this is a population within the
darker part represents the number of
people living within the five geometry
and so and this are added this dimension
is showing the people living in the
10-kilometer radius then you can see and
this equals our density so and we found
that are we expected Paris could be the
most but and especially the inner city
they have a lot but also a singer
Shanghai is also they have a lot of
people living inside the city in the
inner city and also we found very
interesting aspect that so most of the
city so within the five-kilometer radius
has a more density compared to the
broader think 20 meter radius but only
you see Tokyo has its vice versa so talk
has more density for the rod larger area
that means a 5-kilometer narrow area has
more fewer density and this one is about
the building so we counted all the
building which exceeds a hundred meter
high which is about 300 or something
feat so and of course a London Paris
they don't have so much because of their
policy but anyhow so we can measure the
power of the over vitality of the cities
based on this measurement and of course
you can see a lot of concentration in
the Midtown and also the downtown in New
York but also in other cities like Tokyo
it's more like spreading over make this
is Shinjuku a sub-sub inner city area
and let's see like Shanghai this is a
main axis of the city called a are you
so they have a lot of concentration on
here and this is a periodical
classification of each tall building so
of course the era gets
later so the more building that into the
cities like Shanghai and also this
represents a break down the usage within
the 10 kilometers and then you can see
Hong Kong they have such a lot of
residential towers compared to other
cities and this is a top companies
listed in the global 500 issued by
fortune so and within that this source
so we found Tokyo has the most and also
are not only for the but with the
company's numbers the companies but who
is the revenues together but also Paris
is also having a good point and also the
concentration is very similar to what we
have found for the tall buildings the
next one is the top universities listed
in the Newsweek 500 top universities of
course here's at Columbia University but
anyway we made a comparison both the
number of the schools and also the
students and also the international
students and this time again Paris is
doing well and Tokyo seems to be not bad
but still comparing the international
student numbers or still low position as
well as Shanghai and then let's look at
the theatres in concert halls so these
three cities are they predominate very
well for the numbers theaters as well as
capacities and also there is a very
interesting concentration in each cities
which are well-known was kinda Theater
districts and museums and galleries
different from the what we've seen for
the theaters but still concentrating in
inner city like 500 meters on especially
especially for these three cities and of
course these three cities are and Tokyo
somehow we found a lot of museums
similar a number to these top three
cities but comparing the annual visitors
for the we tried to find out all of the
museum's but we it was impossible so we
just picked up the best one in each
cities but still you can see these three
cities are getting a lot of people
attractive compared to these cities and
the stadiums so we did also the similar
thing so it's a number of the stadiums
and also the number of the seat so and
then these cities are strong but also
makes us feel sickly like soul in
Shanghai they also have a good number of
these stadiums and Convention Center we
counted basically these are our
exhibition hall so it doesn't include a
small conference rooms or such
facilities in the hotels so just a pure
convention centers so and New York has a
lot but in terms of the number of the
floor for the exhibition floor so the
Paris seems have the most and as well as
Shanghai and next our embassies and
consulates so so all cities are very
international so there are not souls
such a big difference is from Kampala
just except for Shanghai but it's rather
the interesting thing we found this
concentration in its area so so and as
you know this is a un located here and
surrounding the UN so we have we see a
big concentrations and also on London
Paris so they have a big concentration
is the place it could be very kind of
having good ground or
a wealthy place and similar thing is
happening to Tokyo if this is a place
called minute or a chair our company is
also located here but anyway so some
interesting feature can be read in the
distribution of these things and
international school so we expected it
it could be very similar distribution to
the embassies but some place yes
someplace not always but anyhow the top
is the number both numbers Hong Kong and
also by the students it's the tapas
Singapore so these two cities are pretty
strong in this area and hotel luxury
hotel so we picked up over the five-star
hotels and so this is numbers of tells
and also this numbers ruined so the
numbers of tolls or Paris has a lot but
it seems they're pretty tiny hotels and
so it and on the other hand so these
asian emerging cities they have a larger
scale size of hotels and are now growing
more and more and restaurant so top
restaurant how do we define so we picked
up these Michelin listed restaurants and
also the world 100 our restaurants call
is also published and we found Tokyo has
quite a big number of those evaluative
restaurants and the brand a shot so we
picked up the shops operated directly by
these famous brands mostly from Europe
and also one from America and this time
again our Tokyo has quite a big number
as well as a soul in Hong Kong so it's
very interesting that they are selling
the European brands in age yes
and these are kind of breakdowns and
also we can see the concentration in
very very limited places which has a
very strong commercial accumulation and
shopping center large-scale shopping
center is very similar q Malaysian to
the brand name shops but we counted
major large shopping centers and
department stores in these cities inform
the number still Tokyo has a lot and
also Shanghai as well and this is
another aspect of the the shopping
centers well we picked up the major
shopping centers and counted operating
hours per week and these are the
comparison so the agency T seems to have
more operating time compared to the
western cities and hospitals so with the
hunt more than hundred bit I was
Hospital we've accounted all the numbers
and also the numbers a bit and
accumulated so and this time you have
Paris and Tokyo they dominate and also
New York has a lot of hospitals and on
about the green and water coverage so we
saw the natural environment could be not
only it could be composed of green space
but also the water it's also important
to feel that a nature living while
living in inside inner city so and we
counted all the green spaces and also
the water spaces and um and made a son
so and of course a Hong Kong and soul
which has a big number amount of green
and also
you know water these two cities are
kinda exceptional these cities but also
still in New York has a big number of
green in those water and like looking at
all like Paris has major big green and
also London also has quite smaller but
has even our distribution in spaces
while our Tokyo and Shanghai looks very
poor compared to these cities okay and
the truck transportation so subway and
rail transit so we counted all the
number of the station so not only the
subways but also the irregular trained
in other's makeup and so we found aa so
within the 500 meter distance radius so
Paris has the most that means that the
station density is the most part but if
looking to the wider broader area so
Tokyo has more and also you can see
London has also kind of very even
distribution of the station compared to
that Paris and New York also has a very
good distribution in this new york city
side but the other side the New Jersey
side are it's very few stations and and
this is highway comparison so the lens
of highways will compare go quick yeah
but somehow Tokyo has a lot
and anyway then finally the airport
access so it's a comparison was a time
from the very center of the seat so it's
not only the train but sometimes it
includes a transit so like sitting like
a Paris so we have to take a metro and
switch and then so so this case so Tokyo
is not the worst but at the soul it's a
better the worst time but looking at the
number of the time that's a time the
drive distant because of the bus so
sometimes the traffic jam happened so
it's very difficult to count the time so
we just are colgate the distance and of
course the Tokyo and the naruto report
maybe many of you know but its forces in
terms of distance and also comparison of
the fair of each like a rail and also
bus and taxi so you can see how Tokyo's
taxi fare is expensive so you shouldn't
take a taxi when you can feel okay and
this one is the connection and make a
performance of the airport like so so
number the runways old added together of
course New York has three major
international airport so it's a pop then
this one is also we all counted the
cities with the direct flights and also
counted souls are a number of the
flights then of course London Paris are
they have a lot in the within their
European zone the bigger circle
represent more bigger amount of the
lines running and so these also
represents represents a connection of
the cities between each other so like
New York is connected very well with you
know foresters house American cities and
also and major cities in Europe as well
in Asia but looking at Tokyo so you can
see a big are red in Hawaii so but
anyway and also need one but compared to
like New York you can find a different
situation here also like Singapore is
more concentrated in Asia through Europe
and those Hong Kong has a very strong
maybe to some European cities and also
American cities and so may be similar to
Tokyo and Shanghai is still it's ending
up in age so anyhow so this is a
conclusion of our study it's not
completed but it's almost so we
automated all the aspects I showed here
so and you can see the very densest part
is a kind of what we are defining as a
powerful places and so this these charts
are they are not always are representing
all the sum of the dots but so each each
category has a so we changed to the
index score so so we have 20 indicators
so we change the work so each indicators
200 point scored so the theoretical one
hundred percent should be two thousand
point so and any also and then we also
took took into account not the quality
but like a number not only the number of
the facilities but also the capacities
or like that then oh yes the sea so the
Paris with this method collocation it
stays on the top and then Tokyo follows
and somehow on Hong Kong it seems to be
more than 0 and then London come within
the 10-kilometer analysis
calculation so still Paris Tokyo pounds
and then New York and London and then
Hong Kong and for this and also an other
unique thing is one soul it has very low
score within the 500 meter but is that
within the 10 kilometres on so it has
more sport so that mean isn't worried i
rewrite get stronger so anyhow but it's
not our purpose to make a ranking here
again so we want to rather analysis each
city so but i have time to go over all
cities but you see like so this red is
showing the score or the it actually is
a deviation score for the five-kilometer
radius and this blue zone is showing the
score for the pink kilometer radius
stone and then you can see which our
area has a stronger power and also if
it's a regular shape or very like odd
shape with tokyo like see these like a
singapore and hong kong so they have
much more stronger power for the final
narrower area but a while so has much
more power is in the broader area and
finally looking at the details of tokyo
also and as i introduced so the
population is in the very poor of the
city is pretty small means of course
small and also the buildings it's seems
to be getting better but now compared to
other on our city so still in the middle
on the way and the company is
there's big amount and the university is
pretty well but these theaters and
museums still average our little lower
and stadiums somehow there's big stage
and in very core of the city and
convention are it's pretty middle and
embassies are like this situation and
also international school are not always
so much and especially the hotel's
number the good hotels five-star they're
still quite a few and quite small number
within these HCBS but see this big gap
so the restaurants and branch out and
shopping centers so such so Z is kind of
like for the mass consumption City there
they there are a lot within the most
high 30 meter and 10 kilometer distance
and hospitals as well a very good number
but the nature is not so good in the
station highway very good and these
international airport things are very
bad so this is kind of findings of the
strengths and weaknesses of Tokyo within
the part the inner city so
then I still have another presentation
how we can apply these findings it's a
bit about advertised of our sponsor more
guilty so here I just go a bit quickly
it's okay so um and I'm gonna do as a
architect plunder Moria give this time
so then so we find a bunch of strengths
and those weakness of Tokyo one
especially the inner cities and so so
these are as I mentioned so and the
current problem of Tokyo is is the
structure of cities very work based this
picture for the inner city and also that
there is a long distance community
commuting and also the the city's
structure like it's more like
consumption oriented rather than the
cultural interaction oriented and also
international interaction the business
is it proceeds more than the life
interaction especially for supporting
people and also there is a small space
of nature so these are kind of problems
could be a business channels or
developer like more dealing so I'm just
going to quickly so what Maury building
is doing at the minute award which is
also in the inner on heart of Tokyo so
the current situation you see this is a
major development down by more buildings
called upon hills and this is another
one by down by the other developer but
it's pretty pretty successful but still
see you can see many congested our
particle things still
running around the city it's very and
also dangerous in terms of disaster and
this is a missile to create the kind of
compact city so this occupies only three
percent of the land by the building so
then they just building a house all of
these are tiny houses and more and other
space it can be returned to the ground
earth so what Maury buildings calling
this scheme is a vertical garden city so
let's make a garden city vertically with
the with more of green space on the
ground and also even you utilizing the
underground this and so this business
scheme so so we switch these are people
to get into the new buildings and then
create a more floor and then more
building utilizing this but while
returning the other spaces to the public
so and this is a model case as our cues
and also the rope on hills i mention and
also other projects has been done for
this like a 2010 10 to 20 years and
these are the kind of cultural instances
in open field there's art museum and
also observatory and the club and also
the US have anechoic schools on and also
hotel and akka TV station radio station
movie theaters but not only create
providing those facilities but also many
activities are
produce buy more building and also the
open green space so it's pretty dark but
the Japanese are guarding and also it's
a roof garden on the top of the theater
and actually these are the rice paddies
so the people living around the place
they can enjoy planting and also the
harvesting device and this is another
one in our cues so it's just actually
this is a garden created on the top of
the theater so it's like none like this
and coming back to Roppongi Hills again
so this before the redevelopment so and
actually the increase our the green
space but maybe about seventy percent ET
pricing also our pills again after the
completion after 10 years so it becomes
it more green growing and also this is a
thermo photo order upon Hills area so
actually can see previously they had a
big many still there are many heat
islands but this this new development
places this has a cooler temperature and
this is a kind of that Yeti he used to
be a fire car used to be running like
this way but now can run like this but
anyway so it's a birdcall Garden City
can be a solution to overcome the
problems in Tokyo what more living is so
so and it's based on the large-scale
mixed-use development and also
attachment of cultural facilities and
all in one city and taller buildings
with green spaces and Robles city people
can escape into and finally I like to
improve the latest project done by
currently you do it it's running by mori
building and also the government
together so there is a scheme to make a
loop road
the inner city but it's been taking more
than 60 years and this is the most
critical part which is called MacArthur
street so this is referred to General
MacArthur so this it is said this it
this is his scheme to connect the
support area in Tokyo and this is
American Embassy so to create a good
Street but it never happened for 60
years so now with more rebuilding so
using our scheme so it's going to be
emerged so what we are doing is to
create tower here and put the people are
so many people now living here but to
move them into this building and then
create the street with the building and
also running under down underground
l'interview and based on this mark rosas
three so and then more buildings trying
to expand the kind of call of vertical
burning cities within the minute 0 or
over area under the grand design ok
let's finish thank you
and then I like to switch the pita
okay my name is Peter marco tulio and i
was asked to be part of this urban
strategies institute in terms of
collecting some data for them in terms
of their global inner-city index and as
you can see from the past two
presentations there what is a tremendous
amount of information here lots of
potential analyses and lots of
interesting things that can be done
rather than do any of that what I think
I would might be helpful given my
background it would be to try and play
some of this work in context and to
bring it up to where I am working now
which is dealing with globalization and
urban development and in the environment
so so let's start with the issue of the
title global global power City Index oh
so that's to me that's reminiscent of
the global cities literature and when I
look at work like this and particularly
comparative work across scale such as
this I it it resonates with with that
extensive work and as I as I look at it
I can see that there are at least three
lines of research that have flown
together to create this type of this
type of an ounce
certainly it was the work of John
Friedman in the 1980s who outlined what
he called the world's information
process and for us identified some
propositional effects of competition
global flows investment etc etc on
cities that quote-unquote articulated to
that of the global system he also
invoked some notions of core and
periphery and semi periphery those used
by people in the dependency theory
literature and was obviously there for
looking at and very interested in under
development and inequality at the global
scale trying to explain why you had some
cities increasingly improving in their
accumulation of capital while others
others were suffering now the second
line of literature was supplemental to
that also related global flows of
capital and finance to urban development
but in a comparative fashion and misses
and a lot of this work out its
inspiration from David Harvey who was
looking at the shifts in what he called
the circuits of capital and development
cycle in cities and global finance and
how that flew how those flows came into
and out of cities and help them develop
or not a lot of studies in this regard
looked at comparison of cities New York
London Los Angeles these kind of things
and how finance changed and subsequently
how this spatial arrangements within
those cities has changed and finally the
third set of research
that helped to create the global cities
paradigm related to what we now call
look research on producer services the
office economy capital finance and these
kind of things that we see in cities and
as you know the key to the global cities
literature is this notion that those
cities that are on top of the hierarchy
the ones that were noted by Professor
Sakawa had their basis their economic
basis as centers of the concentration of
some of these services it was these
researchers in these various fields that
started to cross-reference each other
etc and finally in the 90s we had Saskia
Sassen on one side and Anthony King on
the other that developed a fully-fledged
theory of global cities King looking at
the long-term historical trends and how
London influenced them cities in the
developing world and subsequently were
influence on the structures in London
and Sasson focusing on New York Tokyo
and London and the extended financial
and production systems and how these
particular sites became those of the
production of specialized services once
this literature was formed there was a
explosion of research around the world
and that was part of what I was involved
in late 1990s and at the turn of the
21st century working for the United
Nations University we looked at
globalization
global economic restructuring and Urban
Development around the world including
and those cities in Asia Latin America
Africa central Eastern Europe as well as
those in north america and in western
europe and as these studies started to
evolve researchers you know notice that
there was some what they called dirty
little secrets about them and the dirty
little secret was that many researchers
were presuming connections and presuming
that there were flows between and among
these cities and not actually measuring
them there was a lack of empirical data
at the city scale to really identify
linkages and subsequent to that there
were two sort of splits in this
literature to sort of research tracks on
the one hand you had people saying you
know what we really need more urban data
and I think that this effort comes is in
that vein that people were looking for
attributes within cities particular
aspects of individual cities that they
could then collect bring together and
compare and on the other hand you had
people suggesting that well it's not
really the attributes that are important
it's really the connections between
cities so you had a group of researchers
that were stimulated let's say by the
work of Peter Taylor and his group they
were actually looking at relations
between cities and here they
concentrated on sort of flows between
cities and connections between companies
within cities etc and they developed not
only their own extraordinary databases
but actually special analyses in which
they created their own hierarchies and
you probably read some of those
studies but either way all of these
studies are trying to look at and trying
to identify the relationship between
globalization writ large and an
international hierarchy of cities their
objectives seem to be to ground flows
and activities in the development of
these places and to to examine why it is
that despite vast and rapid
telecommunications and transportation
systems we even still have cities why
they still are important now I think
what we need to do for a one second is
to concentrate on this difference
between the act the studies that look at
attributes of cities and those that look
at relations because there is underlying
these types of studies fundamental
differences and they relate to as I see
it the definition of the city do you
define a city by the attributes in it or
do you define a city by sort of
processes and linkages and these kind of
things now in the environmental arena
which is where I am right now this is
incredibly important because what what I
think that we need to do increasingly is
to identify the benefits and costs of
dense settlement on the environment and
in this way we need to know what it is
that dense settlement brings to social
economic environmental systems all too
often and you'll see this in the
environmental literature cities are
blamed their blamed for being
environmental villains and in my mind
those studies conflate lots of processes
on cities that do not relate
to sit eNOS or dense settlement so in
these are the environment so for example
you'll have Lester Brown always blasting
cities for the fact that they are
disproportional consumption centers etc
etc but my question always is is that if
you took those same activities and
spread them out across the landscape
would you get similar environmental
impact worse environmental impacts or
better and this really relates to a
large agenda that is looking at the
environment and and cities now bringing
that back to this study I think that
what we have here is a certain of the
previous a trip attributional studies
that looked at cities because previously
what people were identifying things like
simply the number of transnational
organizations in the economic structure
etc etc the number of banks these kind
of things what I think this noose new in
study that bringing that that was just
presented brings to us is a much broader
set of issues and they actually are
including things like livability
environment and accessibility sort of
environmental issues into into into the
study and end this research agenda so
whether you know what exactly is the
correct way to look at these to look at
cities and the divine global city pneus
will be subject to the kind of questions
we asked I certainly think that this
type of work is an advancement and is
much needed I think that a lot of the
data here can be used by other
researchers that are doing comparative
studies and I think that this particular
study is one that
continues to look for and identify what
global city pneus is in these RV the
position of cities in a in a hierarchy
and I think I'll leave monster into that
and let the other discusses thank you so
I just are for what the introduce
professor market Oreo is also serving as
a committee member for the inner-city
study sorry I forgot to introduce
you know and the stuff was very
interesting and one of the things
there's a couple of things that struck
me one of the amazing thing is that a
mass amount of information that you were
able to look at I mean that amount of
criteria but one thing that struck me
was two things what what what are we
missing I guess it's kind of question
your kind of oil and I'm wondering why
focus and then obviously you're making a
global power and next but can you not
learn something from the other end of
the spectrum those cities that didn't
make it to the top like that that would
be one question I would ask the other
thing that I wanted to struck me about
this presentation was the application of
the data right so if you've done such an
extensive amount of research and looking
at where of the cube is kind of play out
then how do we use that information to
make better cities it's supposedly or
how do we use it to inform our cities
and
a new kind of way and I know that you
presented your your one application but
I was curious about how the intervention
of macarthur boulevard related directly
to the city in this you have a lot
questions to us and the first one is of
course whenever we say just very we the
city's clarity fascination so many other
things so just some story we did this
shocking when i started is working two
years ago already there are several
famous city ranking in the world now and
such as financial center ranking
positive london also did some ranking by
Price Waterhouse and Cooper's and also
another vanitha done by master calm and
we found when about they say the ranking
you see he you a fashionable city there
I'm ingested these rankings for based on
main leader economic economic or
appoints only that so the our ideas were
may be similar to you whenever we see
the city we see so many in a variety of
viewpoints it depends people people has
a different preference to see anything
so it's quite different from this kind
of economic base data so finally which
all six functions to evaluate cities
rankings but still of course something
missing yes it might be a more
possibility to find two
evaluate city is Corey key and the
functions are characters so well maybe
your Christian should be in a semi to us
the may be continuing for the next
year's and the four for the future
whenever we think of other the city's
good points maybe still have to do the
everything or move my things from all
now and second the question is very
interesting for us also first of all re
next year maybe january we issue the
yoke of eau de seguro prosthetics so
this year book has a more data that we
studied to make this ranking so that
many scholars have a good chance to use
data based on this yogic and for the
result of this ranking is already had
influence to japanese government local
government because whenever we show the
disc ranking our chopra's government
center government and tokyo government
try to contact to us get more data from
us because these are very important
issue to evaluate their party city and
they all say oh we already you know
announce the weak point of tokyo so next
stage is you know not only using the
data but the government have to change
the policies so in such case this kind
of habit it's very important for them to
persuade to change policies this is the
power now you know thinking about
so about the second question so yes and
also the very purpose is actually uh so
I also belong to more unity and then we
really wanted know the real position of
Tokyo so and we refer to many rankings
but many are you know they have very
different so you know perspectives and
also there was a result so and we try to
do then let's do by yourself so that the
very start of the during the rankings
and also the inner city especially so
and actually the president mr. Mori
maybe we shall knows a lot but he is a
very aggressive guy they may want to
make Tokyo better city and he's done a
big achievement since for like 30 or
more years and he's quite confident that
Tokyo has been very good city so and
then ask them ask so then measure well
how talk is good and then we submitted
so still there are many agendas we have
to cope with so and that's why we are
still doing this and also and all and
also a professor Scott mentioned we are
not only doing the analysis for Tokyo
but also wanna do utilize this poor
promote other cities like Tokyo yeah
well it already we should just run
from the well now only 35 cities some
opposite is a while requested to us to
make ranking and some city said why our
city is you know adopt in this list so
now we found that many cities are now
trying to find their you know big points
under
points and that should be important to
make for them to make a new policy but
this out
it's fascinating fascinating study and
index and it's interesting that you've
now chosen to choosing to do this
intercity index hi let's try to
understand though the way to think about
the meaning of all of this in terms of
cities representing power and because
you know it's not like Athens and Sparta
we're not going to fight cities fighting
right so instead the implication is one
of competitiveness right how well we can
compete with one another but even that
doesn't sindhu a zero-sum game it seems
like there's an idea that they can all
do better in the rankings through
adopting certain policies and that that
that that by being higher in the
rankings that there's some imputed
social value there's some social value
becomes out of it so it's not just
economic value but it's this idea that
as a consequence tax base is healthier
there are better schools that are better
parks there's you know less poverty
because there's that implication it's
not quite overtly stated and one of the
places that implication I think comes
out I think is the persistence of Paris
in all the data right because if you
it's just fascinating to me if you
MacArthur the MacArthur project that you
presented at the end the city of the
major ranking cities that were presented
that would probably be the least
friendly towards a proposal like that
would be Paris right and I just find
that I find that interesting in the
Tokyo just having returned from there is
city that in many ways is very much I
think emulate certain parts of Paris in
terms of the sort of microscale culture
much more so in many ways than New York
and so what I'm wondering is that you
know is it is it an either or in other
words you have to choose
who's between a very sort of large-scale
development approach right that's that
that's represented in New York Tokyo to
a lesser degree London versus a more a
policy targeted more towards with
culture and social justice and the
things that you might find more
predominantly in pairs actually I first
as shown in the slide about the current
situation of me not the world in Tokyo
yeah so you could find many recently
nearly development versus a tiny
congested are you know existing old
houses mix so of course we don't wanna
you know we're not wishing to change all
the landscape to the high-rise buildings
but the current situation is actually
it's very dangerous because we are
expecting a big huge earthquake within
30 years visit with eighty percent of
the pushing the chance not pushing
chance so by that then we have to change
the situation otherwise many people will
be dying so it's already expected so so
but it's not always that meaning that we
have to change all them to the high-rise
but it could be very pretty available
mix but anyhow are most of the tiny
those houses are expired in terms of
their their their performance so many
are exceeding like five fifty years or
more based on by the wooden houses so we
have to do something for that and at the
urgent matter Tokyo especially the inner
city
so and under straight this is my answer
it's going to be monster but so it's not
always like Paris but but yeah I'm of
course it doesn't always have to be like
come across as it's kind of a special
specialized on and of course there could
be a mixture of the ACNC Tojo maybe two
answers about your fish first monitor
how we could renovate the city center in
total now the first one side like that
showed the project down by new building
but not only Borton mori that commits
additionally we have several garage
developments they are doing just a
similar thing in different area photo /
had a several marked across the city
center hi Connie home Bosque Mar anoche
da pungi Shinjuku so it's quite
interesting every area is very close to
some some special reference so in case
of rope only a morir has a kind of
leadership idea so in different area
different developer health initiatives
to make their own new towns on your
cities a point here now is first of all
whenever we discussed the high-rise
buildings or super-hardened britax every
time we have many objections and
complained people they don't like higher
ratings so this will be given to a new
york manhattan but now even that the
center of the city over the center of
Tokyo changing now the gradually how
does the bay this is constructed of a
big difference from Malta is wherever we
construct buildings we have so many
green works it should be set every time
the typical pattern is shown in the rope
on the huge area once more building
it's a beauty they have only six hundred
percent volumes not to Allah have the
percent but at the same time libero
disturb are constructed many area of a
perks and preserved one they all are
gardens this is a sterile Tokyo's
construction for her the Beatles now and
of course these readings are the kind of
mixed use functions every time not only
of spaces but also many other in a kind
of the functions that is a system
without happy and second the point about
that either by in case of market are oh
no after the war because I came into
Japan he came into todos if there and he
said we need another firm one impossible
at stage to the port but you know after
he ordered it took 60 years pistilli are
doing it understood once we decided upon
Peroni it's never changing and doing but
the story is different from the original
plan now Maka's are all had underground
street now services for the mainly for
pedestrian space so it's a kind of
different style because of the request
of the people of preference of
everything and also the technocratic
already developed so changing but still
we keep the prep with and from most root
of the problem was just as shown 1923
after the canto great asking after that
total social promote show and after that
now more than 80 years we still keep
that to the story a total
dr. reason took a change in the avaya
gradually still got Dewey that's a story
yeah one of the things I like about this
project is that it has an emphasis on
policy and not only an emphasis on
policy but that the creators of this
index understand that it's just a tool
it's just a tool it's it's one it's a
diagnostic tool it can tell you how you
stand in relationship to other cities
and secondly it's a policy tool it can
identify where you're strong and way you
weak in relationship to other cities one
of the things that they didn't talk
about is they do something called
scenario analyses or what i would call
sensitivity analyses in which you would
you imagine that you changed one of
those indicators that for example you
added another one way to the
international day of court while you
lowered the corporate tax rate you do
the analysis and you say okay if we add
another one way how does it change our
ranking or if we lower the corporate tax
rate how does it change our ranking so
it gives you a sense mobility to talk
about what you might do and what it
might what consequence it might deliver
for you in relationship to the index
that I like but I have some problems
with this too and the problems I have
with it are have to do with urban space
and with what I'll call urban time on
the space side this goes back to a point
PETA made about how do you think about
cities if you think of them is what I
call isolates there's individualistic
and fully formed and really somewhat
disconnected to other cities then that's
one thing but if you think of them as
related in networks rather than is that
is that when they act there's a reaction
by the other entities in the network
then this changes your whole sense of
policy so one could if you think of
cities as network you could say well if
I added
one way what do I expect the other
cities to do well i would expect them to
respond and do something so that they
don't lose their competitive position so
that in order to really do a policy
analysis here you can't just look at
what you do you have to look at what
other cities will do in response and
it's very likely that if you add a
runway someone else will added one way
to there at the National Airport no one
wants to live there competitive position
in this global game so that really
changes the way you think about making
policy recommendations the other aspect
of this that's important if you begin to
think about cities and networks then
many of the cities that these cities are
networked with are not on the index what
are the important cities for New York
City white plains Jersey City Washington
DC Stamford Connecticut none of them are
on the index like none of them are on
the index or if you were going to do an
analysis of New York City you would have
to bring those cities into the index in
order to understand what New York City
can do I mean one of the things we know
about analyzing world cities is unless
they're tightly integrated into their
national networks of cities they can't
be will cities so that your your ability
to be international depends on your
ability to integrate back into the
national network or at least the
regional network and that's what I don't
that's one of the things i don't see
here in this index and one of the places
this index could go in the next step the
last comment I'll make has to do with
time and policy you can't make policy in
what I call the eternal present the
policy that you can make depends upon
your past on how you've come to where
you are you can't change the corporate
tax rate unless you understand how the
coalition's were formed to set that tax
rate and those coalition's are not going
to easily change you have a lot of work
to do in terms of the history of your
city
in order to understand how you can make
policy in the future you know Pittsburgh
Pittsburgh enum the United States the
city and the metropolitan area for the
last 50 years have lost population
Pittsburgh's not in a great position to
increase its competitiveness within the
national system of cities it's hurting
it's doing very poorly other cities
though that have been been growing very
rapidly and been doing very well there
in a little bit of a better position to
change their competitiveness to increase
their attractiveness history is very
important for thinking about policy you
don't know where you can go unless you
know where you did those two things are
connected to each other and again I
don't see this in this index if I were
you know if I were advising them would
say the next step is to put time into
the index you need to put time in the
index index it's all about past present
future well not necessary accorded to
your question just now this year we are
studying the tenacity not ranking but
the nasty study maybe in the future
trying to make up our community center
monkey next year we are trying to make a
matter of with an area rug while you sit
in case of in a new yoak here the
connecticut in usually is aimed to Tokyo
so wider area is more important to
evaluate the the city the parotid set so
maybe we need a city set this kind of
GPCR a drunken also the inner city
ranking under multiple talaga ng so this
might be a set to evaluate the powers of
a city but still disowns apart and again
this should be in some important future
to affecting the policymakers oddity
this is our starting point now but is
already starting nine Japan it's kind of
quadratic force already the people in
the government try to find what weak
point
total and this is the first point for us
to say you have to change here and the
finer it is kind of publication where
you know as exploring to the many
readers so maybe that some affection
I didn't know I was moderate in that
case perhaps maybe we should open it up
to the audience may be some people want
to ask some questions anyone okay no she
is that you
thank you Bob brought about the
discussion of the network cities how
cities network I was wondering if part
of your study includes flow of resources
in and out of the cities you study
developers let's say energy food
distribution water in terms of
evaluation of the city and its potential
for growth and change because ultimately
those resources are pretty critical part
of the economic index of it which may
change if the potential of that city to
grow in a certain manner well when I
started this ranking the way chose about
a list over 300 indicators and of course
including everything there but after
that first of all whenever we say
ranking we have to compare the data in
different cities all over the world if
we chose only several cities that has
enough data including not only the
quantitative data but also the creek the
date of authority we can do that but I
it's possible only in token New York
maybe round on the Paris in other city
it's quite difficult to compare so
whenever whenever we set the ranking we
should take the same labor of data in 35
cities finally many indicator the
dropped off so whenever we do this kind
of ranking of course we have uh some
weak points at the data as you said so
well this is the cookie no no the
because of ranking we have to you know
delete many important indicators so this
is only the world difference for people
to understand this is our understanding
so far and 35 cities are quite
small numbers of ranking but cities for
ranking in other ranking system there
were more cities it means well every
time we have to you know all just try to
be careful of the data availability for
other ranking system and I found many
you know programs for many other
rankings but because of comparison we
have to some kind of compromise to do
this is about the cinema and I
understand the USA of course yes but so
far for making ranking in the many
cities you have to do the difference in
this stock answer
have you considered looking at primary
education or concentration of poverty
your question is expenditure of
education and the level of the income
level since Allegra perkily it could be
in a data in NATO nations for the
property still this time we just
investigated the date of un some of the
data source over you and it's quite a
fuzzy and not necessary trusted for some
reason to use for poverty well this is a
sake 50 top cities and properties of
course important not issue but not for
the important inference for making
ranking and we didn't teens so the
expenditure for education where our
number of schools over some other data
or number of researchers and others
which all but expenditure itself is not
used because in a different country of
the different system especially for your
city ranking what is the country city so
they develop it is a very different
topic force to do that so some some data
is just come from national data and
using by our own you know the
understanding but whenever we say such
kind of a big issue for the education
expenditure administering good for
ranking city it is outstanding it's okay
goes back to Sasuke a sense of who began
her discussion looking at inequality
measures and polarization within global
cities and I think that this is I think
that it's really an interesting issue of
whether this is actually perceived in a
global competitive market that you have
this kind of polarization or whether
it's just ignored altogether because you
can isolate you investments in some
parts of the city than rather than
others and you don't have to worry about
those those parts that are not so well
and this is you might know a little bit
more well you only don't Bob Bob up as a
nice well I don't know how much more I
know I mean that the price waterhouse
cooper study actually takes looks at
both of those metrics the one that cited
earlier and so you know i think that
most policy makers would probably agree
that you have to look at a metric like
that in order to understand what the
kind of social aspirations of your city
are and what economic opportunity
represent is represented by any
individual city right as part of its
competitiveness because you know at
least well it's interesting i think to
me that question immediately turns to
immigration and how important
immigration is in most world cities
today and that with a mobile population
around the world people will naturally
gravitate the cities that have more
opportunities for economic advancement
right
for look access to education look to a
whole series of other metrics and so I
actually I mean politely disagree a
little bit about the fact that I
actually think it does those are factors
that I think do influence
competitiveness and about networks
between cities were Ostia provo post
index year 2009 we show the three cases
over networks level between cities from
the viewpoint of F right connection and
hit reporters on the branches for the
financial industry companies also no
financial aid countries because of the
idea of global circuit of assassins and
of course each city has connection each
other in the world now we have to see
such kind of you friends each other and
the last year we did that analysis but
this year we didn't the reason is we
found the connection each other but how
we could you know Explorer develop this
kind of a connection so this year we do
that but still we think is very
important issue the networks of big
cities and this is the data and wherever
you access to the money memory
foundation home pages you can get this
rusty at Roger that the idea of global
sub circuit and we found the part of the
story know how we can you know develop
these connections so this is another
last year
it was a person back in the in the back
row before we get to you a question
hope I have one question actually two
questions one question is what do you
think is the strongest and the weakest
point between a vertical City and a
horizontal City and the second is I've
been reading some articles and Japan has
a lot of problems with family structures
and they have a lot of policies now
especially in cities to promote people
to from single families to get married
and have kids do you think these global
economic power cities have an impact on
these structures and demographics which
is partly answered but what how much do
you think global cities impact on
demographics and family structures in
those specific cities
maybe your are the first question you
are referring to you like Paris versus
the New York like that right yeah and
based on our inner study research so we
found yeah or maybe it's not it's can be
also filled but we found so Paris has a
very very big density but consequently
in the very in their area we found a
very few green spaces so and like near
before there is a big huge central park
but still are like yeah we found our
Paris has a quite small number within
the smaller area so for the green spaces
and but uh they have two big parks right
and maybe they are these parks are
substituting the green space but so but
as we make the city vertical we can get
more green so it's all up to the
immediate preference so which they want
so and like personally I'm living in a
tower now and the view is very nice and
also we get I get the big amount of
sunlight and also we have many green
space around my apartment so I rather
prefer living in such space so that's my
personal opinion though and for a second
the Christians well my understanding
location could be not talking about
demora demographic you know structure in
Japan mature change your population or
just a sterile family well in indecision
ranking every time we do not yeah by ear
now we are just becoming aging society
and
we are younger generations maybe near
future were in a longer term the Tokyo
and Japan will be using the power but so
far as a ranking system I it is only
using the data at a moment so not solely
in principle and maybe next one answer
to you used wherever we do this speech
in a china in Korea I would have they
complain why our ranking it's so small
or something but i have to say every
time we use the 69 indicators we show
the fact ok so the data you know this is
a ranking so maybe ranking results
should be up to to you every but that's
about answer i think okay um my question
is a little on The Skeptical side
especially after your comment that you
said that when you present this data in
Korea and China they say why are ranking
solo and you mentioned that a lot of the
data that you're a lot of the data
sources you're getting your information
from our statistics from your indicators
and now who controls or who creates
those statistics because if it's
governments how do you know that they're
not going to manipulate data later is
there some governments who are probably
more likely to manipulate data over
others so that was a skeptical question
is like how are you controlling for that
so that people or governments don't do
that to an effort to bring up the
rankings in future years
yeah why you said the foot control that
they just and of course a way to write
to find many databases and every time
try to make a similar a bit of us are
250 cities and if some data is the kind
of Christian we did the Bible sales
especially for the case of a number of
international schools the data just open
to open the quite funny so we did
ourselves and also the other already
said to the data of in other nations
whatever United Nations publish the data
did it say anything about their original
source so of course we found there are
funny data there so in such case we did
our original system to find that their
country's data directly to find you find
again and maintain the races so whenever
we can try to do any efforts with it so
so far control or trust abuja up to us
anyway so far but honestly saying we are
quite doing a quite the best job to try
get only the data and 35 cities that a
reason the data over the city's only
limited to 35 cities if we explore the
hefty sativa while the city it imposed
anymore and so if so what happened for
other rankings you know there are
several one already now there are 44
famous indicators in the world now
including us and in case of well city of
London's the financial center ranking
they change every year very different
cities the reason is every year the city
were under had anchored just a
questionnaire to the
the disinvestment so the other business
answers changing year by year so very
different two of you know rankings
happened there but in this CPC I we do
the 53 database within 69 data's
indicators cute easily come from
statistic data so it's kind of quite the
chronological data that never saw
different the other year so still we
keep a stable in the system to get data
and the readership the same every year
this is our stands now and other even
data 11 indicators come from our
questionnaire survey direct said to the
cities that resident there so as far as
i express how the derivative data it
should be reliable for us now and of
course this data will be issued another
year book this coming january so the
graffiti should be naturally open to the
regions so we just need a waiting time
well i guess work at about two hours now
and unless there's a burning question I
think that we should give our presenters
a round of applause and thank you very
much